hey drew
you are one of my favorite chefs on this
planet i'm actually like melting over
here thank you
you deserve to be i've been such a fan
of yours for years okay
i'm so excited by the way i'm i'm going
to show a picture
this is my kitchen by the way um this is
some of my cookbook collection your
cookbook la sun
and these are all your sauces and i have
to say
roy choy you've done it once again they
were the best sauces i've
ever had in my life and
funny enough i combined two
in the dish because i was slurping it up
and they all started to run together
first they were neatly in their corners
and as i grazed it all
coagulated and salivating that's so
awesome that's exactly i mean you did
exactly what i want
wanted folks to do with these sauces
because we created these sauces
to be almost like crayons you know like
you can do anything you want with them
they're really easy you just pour them
together you make your own sauce
out of the sauces and that was the whole
idea behind everything and i'll show you
how easy it is
so the first one is the korean bbq
marinade so for you as a cook all you
gotta do is pour it over
you just pour it over and mix it um
so i think you already have some cooking
over there i had some going already but
i want to show you
so this is the i just poured this over
right now and then this is after a
couple hours
right here and you see how it's broken
down and then what we want to do is just
put that right on the griddle
um but yeah so you just want to grill
this up and then as it's grilling you
want to add these onions and cilantro
so this is just chopped onions chopped
cilantro lime juice and a little bit of
salt
oh my gosh this smells so good put that
in there
great right does it doesn't smell
amazing perfect i'm right there with you
and then so now we're going to let that
kind of do its thing
and we're going to move over and we're
going to start our quesadilla here
okay put the quesadilla on the griddle
or the pan
and then go ahead um and then go ahead
and layer your cheese over the top
we'll do a nice generous layer you know
i like food messy
thank god it's okay to go around the
edges almost
almost i encourage going outside the
lines
you know here and just letting it kind
of like
fall off the edges so you got to keep an
eye on your tortilla what we're looking
for here is obviously you want the
cheese to melt but what we want
on the bottom here we want to create
these blisters within the tortilla
um and then now what we're gonna do
take that cooked meat and let's go over
one side of it
kind of like a half moon and then now
once you do that
we're going to flip it over
and then once you flip it give it a nice
press
we're going to flip it
look at you every time you flip it i
want you to give it a little press give
it a little love press
like that
yeah i'm spanking mine again keep
pressing it
and then now we're almost ready let's go
over to the cutting board look at that
okay we're gonna go to the cutting board
and then at the cutting board
we're gonna we're gonna cut this thing
into four slices and so just cut right
down the middle
and then cut the the halves again
oh you're doing great you're doing
fantastic look at that
there you go and just think pizza slices
oh my gosh
so there you go and then what we want to
do
is we have our orange chili sauce and
just drizzle right over the top
just drizzle over the top i'm going a
little jackson pollock splatter art i
don't know why
there you go and then you can you can
garnish if you'd like
with some cilantro and then that's your
kogi short rib sweet chili
quesadilla now is it okay if i taste
this yes
no oh my god thank you oh my god
that's it look how beautiful that is
thank you so much
roy joy you have been my hero
since i was hold on
i love your food so much roy choi it is
an honor and a pleasure
to finally make your acquaintance as a
huge fan
and an la girl oh my gosh thank you so
much
for this recipe and to get your koji
sauces which will change your life go to
thedrewbermarshow.com
roy choy it is an honor let this be the
first of many thank you thank you thank
[Music]
you